(time code beeps)
(projector clacks)
- To my right is "Bounty Law" series lead
and Jake Cahill himself, Rick Dalton,
and to my left is Rick's
stunt double Cliff Booth.
(energetic music)
So Rick, explain to the audience
exactly what it is a stunt double does.
- Actors are required to do
a lot of dangerous stuff.
(gunshot cracks)
(fist thuds)
(gunshots crack)
(men yelling)
Cliff here is meant to
help carry the load.
- Is that how you
describe your job, Cliff?
- What? Carrying his load?
Yeah, it's about right.
(interviewer laughing)
(frantic music)
♪ La-la-la-la la la la la ♪
- My hands are registered
as lethal weapons.
We get into a fight, I
accidentally kill you,
I go to jail.
- Anybody accidentally
kills anybody in a fight,
they go to jail.
It's called manslaughter.
(boisterous music)
(fists thudding)
(men grunting)
♪ Won't you, won't you, won't you ♪
♪ Make a little money ♪
♪ Drink a little wine ♪
♪ Bring a little lovin ♪
♪ And I feel fine ♪
♪ Come in here and love with me ♪
- [Director] And cut.
(bell dings)
- That was the best acting I've
ever seen in my whole life.
- Like you.
(Leonardo sobs)
Rick fuckin' Dalton.
(gun clicks)
(frantic music)
(Leonardo sighs)
(projector clacking)
- Hello, everyone, and welcome
to the Academy Visiting
Artists Film Series,
FilmAid edition for casting directors.
I'm Bernie Telsey, casting director,
and I'm here today with my good friend,
fellow casting director Vickie Thomas.
How are you today, Vickie?
- Hi, there. How are you, Bernie?
- I'm good.
I feel like I wish I wasn't in
New York so far away from you
so we could do it in-person.
- I know. Well, you know.
I know how hard it is.
- How are you?
I'm good. I'm good.
I'm looking forward to a
very long, long weekend, so-
- Yes, exactly. Yes, exactly.
- (indistinct), you know?
- Well, we're here today to talk about
what it is that you and I
do every day, (chuckles)
and for all these wonderful film students,
so I'd love to start with just saying
how did you get into casting?
And then, how did you transition
into having your own business?
- Well, I didn't get into
casting via the usual route.
I never worked for anyone.
It was really just me
working with a fellow
film student at UCLA,
and they asked me
to cast their student thesis film,
and I went, "Okay."
We would always work
on each other's films,
whether we were making lunch for the crew
or holding a boom mic or...
Everybody just kinda pitched
in and helped each other,
and I think someone said,
"Well, maybe Vickie should cast that,"
and, okay, they asked me,
and I said, "Okay, sure,"
and that student thesis film
evolved over the course of a year
and became a low-budget independent
movie called "Repo Man,"
and they just kept me on
when the film actually became
like a legitimate movie,
and yeah, just sort of got thrown
into the deep end of the pool
and tried to learn
what it meant to be a casting director
or how you cast a film,
so I didn't have the privilege of really,
of working for someone
and sort of being taught the ropes
and coming up through the ranks,
which I would've really enjoyed.
I just kinda, I got thrown in
and I just had to learn how to swim.
- And then, do you
remember this sort of time
when you woke up one day and said,
"Oh, I'm gonna do this for a living
"and I'm gonna do this for my profession"?
- Yeah, it's funny 'cause I did that,
and I went, "Oh, that's
just sort of a one-off,"
and then I think I went
and worked a couple of
other jobs or whatever,
and then I came back,
and the same producer of the film
asked me to help him out in another movie,
and then I got a call that didn't happen.
Then I got a call from
Ed Pressman's office,
someone who actually
didn't know me, (laughs)
so a friend who was giving me a job,
and they wanted to hire me to
be their casting consultant.
I went, "Okay,"
and to cast a movie with David Byrne.
I went, "Oh, okay, sure,"
and I went in my little meeting
and made my little notes and
had my little suggestions
and then, yeah, I think after that I went,
"Oh, I guess I could put
something in that occupation slot
"on whatever piece of paper you fill out,"
and it was right around then I went,
"Oh, I guess casting director."
- Right. That's great.
What do you love about casting?
And what are some of
your guiding principles
when you start casting a film?
- I think I love,
I think, like a lot of casting directors,
I love working with the actors,
just getting in a room, and it's like,
"Let's run the scene
"and let's try something different."
I think just the actual
process of auditioning actors,
which has been a little
hampered by, obviously,
the COVID times we're living in,
but that's really the best for me,
and just seeing someone kind of flower,
see a performance sort of come
alive in an audition room,
and look, I guess, like
all casting directors,
you obviously wanna cast the best,
the perfect person for the part,
the best actor you can,
and hopefully, make some
sort of surprising choice
along the way,
and hopefully, maybe
break someone, you know?
- Yeah, that's the best.
- Yeah, that's really
the exciting part of it,
so yeah, I mean, do you
have any principles?
I mean, just in terms of what do you...
- I don't know.
One of my biggest principles
is just being nice
and being available
to all of the different kinds
of people that we work with,
whether it be the actor or director.
There's such a personality business,
and learning how to be
that host, so to speak,
of how to engage with each person,
whether we agree or don't agree.
- Yeah, and everybody's got a different...
Yeah, so there are a lot
of different personalities,
and yes, it's like surfing.
It's sort of like
just 'cause you, yeah,
there's never one experience
or one type of personality or one...
It's just they're all different,
so you kinda have to be able to adjust.
- Can you share a little
bit about it's day one,
and you're about to
work on this new movie,
and you've read it.
What are those early
first conversations like
with you and a director?
- Well, usually, I like
to have conversations
where it's not just about the casting.
It's sort of the overall
feel of the movie,
the overall story,
just sorta what we're trying to achieve
and how casting can help that,
so I think it helps to be brought along,
as a casting director, into
the filmmaking process,
and just as a fellow filmmaker
'cause we're all, hopefully,
trying to go for the same goal,
and yeah, I just think a sense
of the overall picture,
and yeah, then you, obviously
you get into the casting,
you get into characters, you get into...
I like conversations
where they're sort of,
"Well, who would this character
have been in the '50s?
"What actor would've played this role
"if we were casting this in the '50s
"or the '60s"-
- Yeah, yeah, I like that too.
- like that 'cause that actually kind of,
that, surprisingly, gives
me a real good sense
of, "Oh, it's, okay, well, it's..."
- Well, it's a nice way to start
'cause it takes you out
of talking about someone
in the moment.
You know what I mean?
It's like-
- Yes.
- Kind of-
- Well, it kind of allows you
to sort of...
It helps in free associating,
helps in kind of getting
out of a sort of a
such a maybe a closed off
sort of mentality
about the current actors
of today or whatever,
so it's just sort of
freeing, a little bit,
- you know?
- Yeah.
Well, you-
- And it's fun.
Yeah, you bring up a good point
because so much of the relationship
between a casting
director and the director
is the collaboration
and the give-and-take,
as you were saying,
but what are some of the,
what do you do
when you do come up
against that conversation
about a present actor
that you, particularly,
might be passionate about,
and the director, he or she, is not.
How do you help change
a mind, potentially,
or what do you do when you come
across that stumbling block?
- You know, you sorta maybe plant a seed.
You put a picture over there
and move it along, come
back in a few days,
and go, "Huh, you know?
"Maybe the..."
"No, no, no, no. We don't want that."
"Okay, okay. Well, let's
just go on and keep moving.
"We'll keep reading people,"
and this actually just happened recently.
"No, definitely not.
They're definitely wrong."
"Okay. Well, let's just keep going.
"Let's keep reading people
"and try to find what
you're really looking for
"or that fits your..."
You keep going, and
you go, "You know what?
"That guy, that actor that... (laughs)
"Well, you wanna look at him again?"
So you just kinda plant a
seed, sorta bring it back,
and usually, through
the process of casting,
something may open up
for the director as well
if you sort of are going
for something so specific
that it's sort of you're
not quite finding it,
and then you might find
actually what you're looking for
with an actor that you didn't
expect to get that from.
Actually, what you're talking
about for this character,
this actor actually brings to you
in a slightly different way,
but that might work just
as well, if not better.
- Right, right.
Do you find the conversations
that are happening today,
based on the recent
racial justice movement
that we've all been part
of in the last two years,
have those conversations been easier,
harder to have with creative team members
about inclusion and
belonging and diversity
as far as where it relates to actors?
- Well, easier and harder
because, look, yes,
let's find roles for actors of all races.
Let's reflect a world as it exists,
and if that happens to be
a multiracial world, great,
but also, if it's like,
if we're doing a film about the Amish,
I mean, I don't really wanna
shoehorn a actor of color
into necessarily a film about the Amish,
and you have to be careful.
Sometimes I don't wanna just...
I want the best actor for the part,
and I don't want tokenism,
so how do you...
It's just, it can get a little tricky,
the conversations where it's like,
"Well, it has to be
this or has to be that."
It starts to look like a,
like sort of a Benetton ad
or something that's being put on
not in a natural, organic way,
so that's sometimes, those
are tricky conversations
'cause I think I find myself
sometimes as the only
black woman in the room
arguing for the white actor
to play that particular part.
- Right. Sure, sure.
(Vickie laughs)
- It just, well, I just think,
"Well, that, it just seems
to fit that role better
"and achieve what you're trying to achieve
"if that character is a white actor."
You know what I'm saying?
I know we're all trying to be inclusive,
but just wanna make sure
it's not getting in the way
of what you're trying to do
with the film or the television project.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, no, no, I feel like,
for me, it's been a little,
it's been enlightening, and I don't wanna,
easier isn't the right word,
but now I feel like on day one
the teams are wanting us to
lead those conversations.
I mean, I know you and I have
been seeing diverse actors
since the day we started in casting
'cause why wouldn't you?
It was always better
to play with a bigger crayon
box of actors than a smaller,
but then, the decision-making
is what always didn't
happen until the end,
and then it was too late
to have those conversations
about why can't it be?
And now I find it's like
the first day of school.
I walk in and, "Let's talk
about what this role is
"and what does it really mean?
"And why can't it be or why can it be?"
- Yeah, well, I find that, I think,
these conversations aren't
being led by us anymore.
I think the conversations
are being led by the studios.
They're being led by some producers.
They're being led by
the network or what...
It's like there has definitely been,
in the last, I dunno,
Bernie, what do you think?
Three, four years?
- Yeah.
- We don't have to encourage
anybody to... (laughs)
- Right, right.
We have to remind them.
- (indistinct) mandate.
- Right. Now it's reminding, and...
- Yeah.
- And then, let's talk
about that challenge.
What do you do
when you're faced against the challenge
of the bankable actor
that will bring the financing
to an independent film
or a studio film
versus who might be
better suited creatively?
I mean, how do you handle
those conversations?
- Well, I mean, it's kind of a
reality we have to deal with.
I mean, it's,
and I understand someone is
putting up a lot of money
for a film.
They like to get at least some sense
that they're gonna get their money back
and maybe make some money,
so I understand that.
I think all of that
isn't always guaranteed,
but it's just
I understand people wanting that comfort,
so you just try to
maybe balance the known,
give the, well, this
is the unknown version;
this is the known version,
and if something happens,
maybe you get your lead in this role
and maybe you can slip
in someone less known
who's great in this other role,
but I mean it's just a reality
of the business that we work in.
On some projects, it's a lot more,
like, "No, we need that and we need..."
It's not like a Chinese menu,
but it's just like they
want bankable people
in all these roles.
If it's a big franchise
movie, they want...
- Right. They want-
- That's what they want.
(Bernie speaks indistinctly)
Yeah, and it's you just have
to sort of deal with that,
and like I said,
maybe try to slip in
something a little surprising
along the way
in some of the other parts,
but it's a reality we have to deal with.
- Right. Right.
You've worked on a bunch of films
by the same director or producer,
and can you talk a
little bit, specifically,
about what those collaborations
and relationships are like
and what they were like
from the first time you
worked with he or she
versus now, the fifth
time or, and what those,
and how your relationship
between the casting director
and director grows and changes.
- I guess maybe you develop
a little more of a shorthand
as you work with people more and more,
and with Ed Zwick,
it's like he's my brother.
It's like we argue a lot,
and so it's sort of
almost like becomes sort
of a familial relationship,
but in a great sort of joking way,
but we, I think, feel familiar
enough with each other
to get on each other's nerves
and be fine with the fact
that we're getting on each other's nerves
'cause it's gonna be okay,
and I'm not gonna be thrown
out of the room or something.
With someone like Quentin,
it's just we had a shorthand immediately
just 'cause we had similar
cultural references,
similar film references,
similar memories of
television shows we looked at,
and so we had, we got
along very, very quickly.
- Right, right,
and is it different now working
with Quentin than it was?
- Just as more, just more...
We just laugh a lot.
We laugh a lot more, and just...
It's more relaxed, more comfortable,
just more intimate, in a way,
but it was pretty close from the get-go,
and look,
sometimes you have relationships
with directors, Bernie,
and you work with them,
and sometimes people feel like
they wanna just try something
different or just...
And you kinda, you have to watch
that you don't sort of take it personally
or get hurt by it.
Sometimes those three
films you did with someone,
they wanna go and do something
else with somebody else,
and it's, you just have to learn
how to navigate that emotionally, but...
- That comes with age, right?
- I think it comes with age, (laughs) yes.
Yes, yeah, so that's a little tricky too
because, yeah, you don't,
sometimes you don't do
the five movies together.
Sometimes you do the two,
or sometimes you do the three, but yeah.
- But what I, something
I find when you do,
when you are lucky enough to repeat,
and totally, I agree with you:
you understand they work
with different actors.
They work with different
designers and locations.
Why not a different casting director?
But when we are lucky enough to repeat,
there's such a sense of
it's such a hard process
falling in love with actors
and making that final decision.
Yes, that's who I'm gonna put in my movie.
I mean, we know they're always,
that's always the most
vulnerable for the directors
when they finally have to commit.
It's so nice when you have that trust,
as a casting director, with that director,
that, like you said, shorthand
or when you can go,
"Oh, I know your taste.
"I know what you like.
"Trust me about this actor
"more than you may or
may be seeing right now
"in this audition,"
and I love when that trust is there.
- Yeah, and it's okay to actually,
for them to ask, for them
to say, "Okay, really?
"Do you..."
I mean, for them to really
kinda look at you and go,
believe that they can do it.
They can do it and,
so that's...
Yeah, they're vulnerable,
yeah, they're-
- Yeah, sure.
- 'Cause they've got
a lot on the line too,
just trying to...
They don't wanna make a mistake,
and casting, I think, is a huge part
of the success of a movie, creatively,
especially creatively, so yeah.
- And I've also found the
more we do this, right?
It's always, it's really
one of the first things
that the director is
doing, is committing to,
is actively doing, you know what I mean?
And yet, they're finding their way
no matter how much personal
prep they might have done,
so it's a little bit like,
I know they're not
consciously thinking this,
but I always think it's like,
"Well, if we make a decision
of who we're gonna cast,
"then we're gonna have to
actually go to the next step,
"which is start making the movie."
- Exactly, which is scary, yes.
- Yeah, totally.
- Yeah.
I actually had a director.
We started casting the movie.
They were scared
'cause they were jumping into
some controversial territory,
and I'd gone to New York,
and they were gonna come and meet me
to meet a couple of actors,
and he called me, says, "I can't.
"I can't do it. I can't."
He wasn't ready yet,
and I went, "It's okay."
I think I kinda got it.
I knew that there was some...
It wasn't prima donna behavior.
It was just-
- Right.
- I said, "That's okay. We'll
just figure this out later.
"I'll tell these people you'll
meet them at another time,"
but they were really,
yeah, in terms of that
vulnerability of a director
making those casting decisions.
I mean, you're right.
Now you're committed; you're in the movie.
You're making it,
and that was, yeah, that was interesting.
That was...
It was a lesson in empathy.
I mean, yeah, so yeah.
- Talk a little bit about what
you look for in an audition.
What are the nuances?
Or what makes a great audition for you,
for when you see an actor?
- Wow. How would you answer
that question, Bernie?
- How would I answer?
(Vickie laughs)
I always, obviously, we have a sense
of what we believe the,
what the director is looking for,
and we know what their vision is,
so we have that sense of
do they fit what it is that
we've been told that we need,
but I think, for me,
it's someone that just
walks into that room
and makes me feel something
in whatever short time I'm in the room.
I mean, it's, I know
that sounds corny for me,
but it's like, "Oh, did I feel something
"having heard this 65 times or two times?"
Was there something that made me
'cause I feel like I'm always racing,
like I know what we need.
I know what you're not,
but it's like, it feels
like all time stops
for that half a second
because of something
that the actor was doing,
and they just moved me,
and that-
- Yeah, I think,
I think maybe people don't
realize that what we do is
we may hear something 62 times,
or we'll read a scene and
nothing rises above...
It's just all sort of like
this, and you're right.
At that moment, when someone
comes in and gives it,
yeah, it makes you feel something
or actually makes the dialogue work
in a different way than anybody else had.
It's like that is that moment,
that sort of a-ha moment,
or yeah, the moment that makes you go,
"Oh, shit."
- A-ha.
- I think this part is
actually gonna work,
and there's somebody who
can actually play this part,
even though I've looked
at 100 other people,
and you've gotten depressed because it
nothing seems to be working,
and not that anybody's
giving a bad reading.
It's not that they're all bad.
- Not at all.
- It's just that nothing
is sort of rising above,
and yeah, when someone comes in,
and it's like, "Oh,
shoot, oh, oh, that's it,"
yeah, it's exciting.
Very exciting,
and I don't think you can kinda
define the nuance, exactly.
- [Bernie] Right, right, absolutely.
- Depends on each
particular part, or yeah.
- What are some of the places
that you look for new talent?
Or was there a specific role
of a movie you were working on
where you had to go outta
the box to find someone
that would be a fun thing for
the students to hear about?
Of like that "Detective Thomas,"
where you had to go outside of the norm
to maybe find someone,
or just generally, where do you
like to look for new talent?
- Yeah, just wherever it may be.
I did a movie called "A Family Thing"
years ago with Robert Duvall,
and we were looking
for an older black woman
to play, or like the lead
role, a black matriarch,
and I'd been in Texas years
before working on a film,
and I'd met this woman, Irma P. Hall,
and she just seemed to be great,
and she just was mainly in Texas
and did parts in movies
that were based in Texas
and hadn't really
done anything big outside of
films that were shooting there,
and we lost an actress that
was gonna play this part,
someone more famous,
appropriate, or whatever,
and that (indistinct),
and I just went, "Irma P. Hall."
She's in Dallas, Texas.
She's like doing a play at the whatever,
and it's her.
She came in, and booked it,
and so I guess that's an example, maybe,
of just not necessarily someone
from outside a box, but-
- Sure, sure, sure.
- Someone who wouldn't have
normally gotten that part.
- Yeah, that's the, right, sure.
- And but in, I mean,
look, I think it, also,
it depends what sort of
movies we're doing, Bernie,
in terms of how much you'll
be able to go outside of a box
in a certain way.
There's some films that
lend themselves to,
well, you have to find a short,
a little person,
whatever the specific little thing is.
- (indistinct) put on the detective hat,
and you start looking.
- Exactly, exactly,
and it's fun to enter that world.
I'm looking for a deaf kid right now,
and it's just like,
it's fun to sort of be
an explorer in that world
and really try to find,
whether it's through deaf
societies or wherever,
find someone who could make that,
who could do that part,
so I'll try to figure out a story
of someone outside the
box that I've cast before.
- No, that's all right.
Are there any
well-known actors today,
but when they weren't well-known
or when they were just
starting out in the business,
that they came in and auditioned for you
for a certain project,
but then you now watched years later,
"Oh my God, now they're an Oscar nominee."
Are there any sort of-
- Yeah, you know, Don Cheadle,
who came in, I think, like
in '80, in the late '80s,
he played a soda fountain jerk
in a low-budget movie for me. (laughs)
- Oh my God. I love that.
- Yeah, yeah, when he first start,
think he was at Cal Arts,
but he'd just started.
He did a day. Soda fountain jerk.
I mean, I just remember Catherine Keener
just auditioning all the time
and never getting the part,
but you'd always bring her,
and years later, she said to me,
said, "Vickie, I just wanna thank you
"for always bringing me in.
"I never got anything.
"I just wanna thank you
for bringing me back,"
but you figure these people,
Bernie, they're good.
You bring 'em back in.
Something's gonna hit,
but yeah, I think Don
as a soda fountain jerk.
I mean, look, Gary Oldman
was casting "Sid and Nancy."
We had London and U.S. casting.
He was casting, he was
casting outta London,
and I remember seeing
him for the first time
arriving at JFK in New York
to start work on "Sid and Nancy,"
and there's this like this little guy
leaning against the wall,
and the most unassuming guy,
and it was like that's,
I mean, you would never guess
he would be Gary Oldman,
but he was just very unassuming.
His first big role,
and yeah,
he became what he became.
I mean Viggo was, used
to hang out with Viggo.
Santa Monica, would do like a small part
in a movie called "Roadside Prophets,"
and it's, I don't know.
You see them sort of take off-
- No, I know.
The Viggo story reminds me of
I was casting a off-Broadway
production for Ivo van Hove,
who's a wonderful European director,
but he was doing his
version of "Streetcar,"
and this was way before
he was doing movies,
but Viggo came in,
and it was like New York guy,
and it was like, oh my God,
the most amazing Stanley audition,
and then we offer it to him,
and then, of course, in the next minute,
one of you L.A. casting
directors snapped him up,
and he became a movie star,
and I don't think he even, has
never been back to the stage,
but it was like, "Damn!" (laughs)
But it happens. We all watch it happen.
It's so great when it happens.
- It really is, and he was
sort the reluctant movie star.
He was-
- Yeah, totally.
Probably still is.
- (indistinct) really.
- I don't know him, but.
- We had to kinda really talk to him
to come and read on "Crimson Tide."
- Wow.
- Yeah, and he came in 'cause it just...
He marches to his own drumbeat.
This was sort of a Jerry
Bruckheimer commercial movie,
and you're trying to...
"No, come on in and do it."
It's like "Con Air."
John Cusack and Steve Buscemi
were all independent film guys,
and you say, "Oh, well, come
on for this Jerry Bruckheimer."
(laughs) They had a
certain, and I love Jerry.
He's a great producer,
but he had a certain sort of
Hollywood commercial sheen
that they were not usually in,
and to watch them sort
of do one of those movies
and actually come out the better for it,
I mean, it helped them continue to do
the independent things they wanted to do
and also do, open up,
maybe, an audience for them,
so I don't know.
- How have you felt in these,
in the last few, I was gonna say months,
but it's really, I
guess, almost two years,
casting virtually?
How is that affected?
What are the pros and the cons?
- Well, the pros are you
can see many more people-
- I know.
- in a
shorter amount of time,
so that's kinda great,
but I-
- And from anywhere.
- From anywhere, and you also sort of see
a certain sort of screen
magnitude, yeah, magnitude
is maybe the wrong word,
but does somebody,
is somebody able to hold
the screen a little bit,
but then, look, it's been frustrating
for directors I work with.
They wanna be in a room with an actor
and see them in the
flesh and work with them,
and so in that sense,
I miss the other thing,
but I don't think it's gonna go back
just because there is a convenience to it.
- That's my fear.
I mean, it's gone back in the theater.
I do some theater, of course,
and that's been in-person,
but I do feel like the film and TV
was already leaning towards not in-person,
that now the convenience
for some are outweighing.
- Yeah, yeah.
I miss being in the room with actors-
- I miss it so much.
- Yeah, I've done a few in-person things.
It's usually such a to-do
with the test and thing
and blah-blah-blah-blah,
but it's just really good
to be in a room with them,
but I realize it's just not gonna go back
completely the way it was so.
- We just have to put
singing in every movie
'cause that's been our way.
We're doing the "Wicked" film,
but because we're doing the musicals,
it's like we have to do them in-person.
- Ah, that's good.
- Because
you can't sing virtually,
so it's like-
- That's right-
- Now i'm telling everyone.
Put a song. Put in a song.
- Yeah, so most of your theater things,
you're doing in-person.
- Yeah, I mean, the
prescreens are on virtual-
- Yeah, yeah.
- just one of us,
but the themes, the things with
the teams are all in-person.
- I remember before we shut down,
a couple weeks before we shut down,
someone was saying to me,
"Well, so and so does all their prereads
"with self tapes and
then they pick from those
"who they want to come
and read in-person."
Went, "Really?"
Went, "Oh, huh, that's kinda good,"
'cause I would do all the prescreens.
I would...
- Me too-
- I would do 'em all,
and I was going, but
something in my head went,
"Oh, that's kinda great," (chuckles)
and little did I know
that that was what was gonna
be sort of forced on us
in the next few months, so yeah.
- Right.
Before we get to some of the questions
from our FilmAid students in Kenya,
I would love to ask the question of
what would you tell someone who said,
"I wanna go into casting,"
and they're just getting outta school
and whether there's a job or not,
what would you say to someone
who's interested in casting?
- I think I would sort of encourage it,
and I would,
I would wanna know why. (laughs)
- Don't ask me why.
(both laughing)
- Really? First of all...
No, you know, our job is a
little like psychologist.
It's recognizing talent.
It's a lot of different components,
and
as long as people are
sort of ready for that,
I sometimes, I'm not sure
if people really know
what being in casting means.
- Right, sure.
- So I'd probably ask them
what they thought it was,
what they think they might like about it,
and hopefully, encourage,
encourage someone
who really seemed to have
a passion for actors,
yeah, but I think, I don't
think it's a closed-off,
I don't think it's a closed-off job.
- And I think there's so
much, I'd say a young person,
they can do now, before
even having that job.
They live in the world of the Internet.
Start taking notes
of every film or TV or
theater thing that they saw,
and start to hone in on their taste.
People ask me, "Well, what is taste?"
It's like, "Well, go see something
"and start talking out
loud or talking to yourself
"about what you thought
of those performances
"and who stood out,
"even if it was the one-line part, and"-
- I often tell...
I think a sense of film history
and theater history,
just the great performances,
the great actors.
I always tell actors, "Just
go look at great actors,
"whether they're from the '90s, the '80s,
"the '60s, the '50s, the
'40s are great actors."
I said, "Adopt an actor, and
just look at all their movies,
"and sorta get to know
"what great screen acting could be like."
- I love that: adopt an actor.
It's a great one.
It's a great one,
and I love that suggestion,
too, of watching it in order.
- Mm-hmm. Yes.
- You know what I mean? And you see.
I mean, a friend of mine did it.
Yes, it sounded like fun.
They watched every Meryl Streep movie,
from the first one to the last,
but they really came at it
from a sense of watching the growth.
I mean, yes, you
(indistinct) done day one,
but yes, it's just that's a
really great way to learn.
- Exactly.
- By watching how they change,
how they grow.
- Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly. Exactly.
- Yeah.
No, I think it's a great profession,
and I feel like our profession
has gotten more visibility,
more recognition,
and it's a place to make a living.
That-
- It is,
and I think it's,
I mean, I really do think it's one of,
I think it's all creative positions
on the making of a film
or a theater piece,
but it's you really can impact something
in a big way,
and that's nerve-wracking too.
I feel the burden in a way,
and I just, "Oh my God,
what are we gonna do?"
But it's you can really have an impact.
- All right, I'm gonna ask some of the...
We had some really good questions
from our Kenya FilmAid students
if you have a few extra minutes.
- [Vickie] Sure.
- Great.
How long does it take you to cast
or get the right actor in
the right role? (laughs)
How much time do you have
is the question, right?
- I (indistinct) worked
on something for three months,
and we still hadn't
found the right person,
and that's really sort of
nervewracking, so depends.
Sometimes you get in there
the first couple weeks
(indistinct) or the, you kinda
think you know who it is,
and yeah, three weeks later, four weeks,
yeah, that's who it was,
but I literally worked on some
that were three months,
and, I mean, actually,
it was longer than that.
We didn't have anybody.
It was very nervewracking,
and so it just depends.
Just depends.
- Right, right, I always feel
like there's one role that's-
- The bane of your existence?
- impossible to cast.
- Yeah, the band of your existence.
- Yeah, there's just always one role.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- In your experience, obviously,
maybe they don't know this
or do know this, students,
we do have casting contracts.
Is there anything
that you feel like you
would wanna add to...
Is there something that is not there now
that you would want there
in a casting contract?
- Residuals. (laughs)
- I like it. I like it.
Let's call 399 and 817.
- I mean, I cast the original "Power,"
and that's gone off into like
eight spinoffs or whatever,
and I would love to have like had a...
Anyway, shared in that success
in a longer way,
but let's not talk about all that.
In a contract...
Wow.
- Yeah, but that's a good one.
That's a (laughs) a good one,
or bonuses.
- Something. Something
where you share in the...
- [Bernie] Right.
- The success.
- One of the students' questions was
if you're trying to land
a star for a lead role,
what is your approach?
How do you approach that, specifically,
differently than just casting a movie,
when you know you have to land a star?
How do you go about that?
- Well, hopefully, you have
a director and a script
that will appeal
to that star.
Wow, it's (indistinct) a star.
Through any means necessary.
I mean, that's really,
it's like call the manager.
Okay, let me call him and
tell him this is coming,
just any way you can get something
to make it rise above
the rest of the script
someone's being sent.
Yeah, that's a hard one to sort of...
Maybe the approach is
a little more delicate.
- Yeah 'cause we, all of a sudden,
depending on the level of
the director and the script,
we become salespeople.
- Yes.
- And we're trying to,
I would say, first off,
try to get the agent or
manager to read the script
in hopes of having a conversation
about that actor for this director,
yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
No, we are the sales people, Bernie.
It's, yeah, and that's, yeah. Yeah?
- When you have to work on a project
where you know you're gonna
have to look for people
who have, who don't have a
lot of experience in acting,
like a lot of young
people just starting out,
is there something you
look for differently?
How do you handle knowing that
you're not gonna have a cast
with a lot of experience?
And is that okay?
One of them wanted to know.
- Yeah, I think, hopefully,
you look for someone, even if
they're not that experienced,
who seems to
get better with each audition.
They seem to have a natural
instinct for it.
They seem to,
outside of what you're telling them to do,
they're making decisions about
what to do as that character
that makes you kinda sit up.
It's like, "Oh, okay, they're thinking."
They're not just repeating
just repeating lines or
repeating going down a,
down an avenue that I may suggest to them.
They're actually taking their own accord,
and oh, they're coming up
with something on their own,
so that's, (indistinct),
"Oh, okay, well, that's interesting,"
and hopefully, I think,
maybe what we try to do
with inexperienced people
is maybe surround them with someone
who's a little more experienced.
If you can put someone who's,
maybe you have an actor who
knows a little bit more,
been around a little bit more,
and they can be around
that person's with a
little less experience,
it's just they can kind of,
it's a good influence on them,
so I wonder, was this question
someone who was trying to
figure out how to make a movie
knowing that they're gonna
be using inexperienced actors
and how do you do that?
- I think it was probably,
it might have been from
one of the acting students.
What's it like auditioning
actors who lack experience
or how do you help that?
I think it was maybe,
but I'm not sure if it
was an acting student
or a directing student.
- I'm pretty sensitive to that in a room.
I know there are people who inexperience,
and they don't quite know
where to sit or what,
or how to do it, or what
you just try to help them
in just the act of having to audition,
which is, yeah, that's a learning curve.
- Yeah, and it's reminding them
that so much of acting is listening.
- That's a big one.
- They get in the room
and they start doing,
and so much of film acting
is listening, right?
The camera's on them, and
they're not the ones speaking,
and it's trying to help
them be grounded enough,
to be still enough to just listen
to what is being said and...
- Well, I think something that
you said too, Bernie, before
is trying to be just like
a kind person in the room
so they're not facing,
just so that they feel
like they have a little
bit of support in a room,
you're just trying to be there.
It doesn't do us any good
to not make the actors comfortable.
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean.
- So, you know?
- As much as I love what we
do, and I know you do too,
it still always surprises and amazes me
that how this is how people get jobs,
through the action of auditioning
'cause it's so filled
with so much tension, hope, fear.
Whatever we can do to help
relax it, be in that moment.
- And I think the repetitive
nature of it, I think,
doing it over and over
and over and over again
is gonna help inexperienced actors,
and it's just something you
have to do again and again.
- Yeah, one more question,
I think, from them is
what is it like working
with a first-time director?
- You know, it depends who
the first-time director
is, obviously.
Huh-
- Let's say it's a director
right outta school.
You know what I mean?
Or their first feature,
and you love the script, and
you've decided to cast it.
- Yeah, I got, I think
you have to be there
sort of teaching a certain...
Boy, that's, yeah, that's a whole other,
that's a whole other thing.
It's...
(Bernie laughs)
You're there to guide them,
just to guide them, and hopefully, say,
you're just there to guide them.
It's just a little bit more of a hands-on.
There is not necessarily a shorthand,
and they may not necessarily
have gone through a casting process,
so you really sorta have to say,
"No, you actually can talk to the actor.
"You can actually ask
them to do it again,"
so it's really guiding them
through the whole process
of casting,
and some will have more of a natural...
It's like a duck to water.
They'll get into it
and be better at it sooner than others,
and yeah, it's just you're
their guide and teacher and...
- That reminds me, did you have a mentor
or anyone that guided
you through your career,
or at one time in your career?
- No, I've learned a lot from
people who've worked with me.
I've learned a lot from Jeanne McCarthy.
I've learned a lot from
directors I've worked with,
from Frears, just watching them,
watching him, Stephen Frears,
just see people and make decisions,
and just, (indistinct) I've learned a lot.
It's interesting
how directors come to
who they want for a role.
I've tried to pay attention to that.
Quentin, I mean, just looking at him.
Frears is interesting 'cause he's just,
it's amorphous, sort of.
I really admire him as a director
and as a director of actors,
and it's, I don't quite know
how he does it, what he...
I just try to listen to
how he makes decisions.
Then, later, I'll ask him,
(Vickie mumbles humorously)
(Bernie laughs)
Went, "Oh, okay, okay."
It's just interesting, coming, someone,
some come from like a feeling, from a...
It's just...
I've learned a lot from the
directors I've worked with.
- Yeah, sure.
Do you have a,
I won't call it a favorite,
but is there a movie in your repertoire
that you've worked on
that was just the experience
of casting that movie
was special for such-and-such reason,
whether it was an actor,
director, you know what I mean?
It's not about favorites, like-
- [Vickie] Yeah.
- Can you give a little,
tell us about a specific story
of a film that just, to this
day, you still remember love.
- I think "Ed Wood" was a really,
just great from start to finish.
- [Bernie] (indistinct) love that movie.
- Was working with Tim Burton, who's...
- Oh my God, I forgot you did that movie.
That's so good.
(Vickie laughing)
- It was about sort of
L.A. It was set in L.A.
It was just, as a production,
just a pleasure to work on,
great people who...
Sarah Jessica hadn't
done a million things,
and all these people that were
in it playing small parts,
and it was just a really great...
That was a really fun experience,
and "Once Upon a Time in Hollywood."
That felt very personal, very personal
'cause I'm from L.A.
(Bernie speaks indistinctly)
- All those small parts
in "Hollywood" were
so amazing.
- Thank you.
- It was like you just kept wanting to go,
"Oh my God, who is that?
"Oh my God, that was her?"
(Vickie laughing)
You know what I mean,
but I remember watching that.
It was like, oh, it's so good.
- And just that it was set in,
you know, I would go see movies
up on Hollywood Boulevard
when I was growing up.
I mean, it was just,
and I 'member reading about those murders
and my kitchen table
with my mom and my dad.
It was just, and the cultural
references within the movie,
the TV shows within it, so anyway,
so that was also something
sort of personal,
even though I didn't know those people.
I didn't...
That was great. That was great.
- Wow, all right, I have
a last question for you.
If you were starting all over again
casting from like the day one,
is there something you wish
you knew that you don't know
or that you would do differently?
- I wish I knew that I
was pretty good at it
(Bernie laughs)
at an earlier time
and not been insecure
because the way I started,
I was actually hiring people to assist me
who had more experience than I did,
and I felt a little guilty about that,
and I wish I'd just
not felt that insecurity
and trusted that I was pretty good at it,
and don't beat yourself up.
- Right. That's beautiful, actually.
I still feel like there's
so much we can learn.
I mean, that's what I
love about the job too
'cause we're always
learning-
- Yeah, yeah.
- and if it's just learning a new actor,
it reminds me that, "Oh, yeah,
I do have to keep learning."
- Yeah, I don't feel like I know it all.
I don't feel that way at all,
and I feel like I have to be reminded to,
I have to just remind myself that,
yeah, there's always
something new to learn,
and yeah, yeah.
- And any final advice
you'd give to our students
who wanna go into, who
wanna be a casting director
or wanna be an actor or a director?
- I'd say just have
faith, know your craft.
- [Bernie] That's a good one.
- Always, just always feed yourself.
Just feed yourself,
like I said, with film history,
but also, just live life,
and observe life,
and just travel outside
of your little circle,
and experience the world
as much as you can,
and use that experience
in whatever craft you choose.
- That's beautiful. Thank you, Vickie.
Oh my God, it was so great
to get to hear your story
and how you started in this business,
and this was so nice.
I feel like I know you
a different way now,
so thank you.
- I hope it was,
I hope it was helpful or
enlightening in some sort of way.
- And I wanna thank all of our students
for participating in the Academy
Visiting Arts Film Series,
FilmAid edition for casting directors.